[Música]
les doy la bienvenida al espacio de
cultura de france 24 arrancamos el
programa de hoy con dos miniseries que
se estrenaron en la plataforma de
streaming disney plus la muy esperada
obi-wan kenobi sobre un personaje de
ficción que marcó una época y la
francesa el caso usé kim sobre una
persona real que marcó un país los
fanáticos de star wars están encantadas
de reencontrarse con el famoso de die
obi wan kenobi interpretado de nuevo por
ewan mcgregor 17 años después de la
última película la trama se desarrolla
entre las dos icónicas trilogía star
wars y la miniserie hace malabares entre
los momentos de acción y combate puros y
las escenas más introspectivas son seis
episodios para saborear porque en
principio no habrá secuela a menos que
ante el éxito de la serie y la
popularidad del personaje me snake
cambia de opinión
pero en la plataforma disney plus hay
otra miniserie que destaca es el caso de
china que cuenta un hecho real el
asesinato a golpes de malí cus ekin a un
estudiante de origen argelino de 22 años
por tres policías en
1986 en francia y las mentiras estatales
que siguieron pasaron 35 años pero la
serie sigue siendo muy actual con el
debate sobre las violencias policiales
que ocupa ahora más espacio mediático y
político en francia o en otros países
pero el caso se queda sobre todo el
retrato conmovedor de una familia
quebrada interpretada por brillantes
actores y actrices veamos el trailer
eso más hacer
[Música]
para nosotros
aquí
[Música]
[Aplausos]
para junio les recomendamos también
otras dos series que estrenaron sus
nuevas temporadas y que valen la pena en
prime vídeo los villanos superhéroes y
el equipo que intenta detenerlos desde
voice volvieron en una tercera temporada
tan graciosa como sangrienta y la serie
estrella de netflix reed hastings
estrenó la primera parte de su cuarta
temporada con episodios que costaron
cerca de 30 millones de dólares cada uno
una inversión que se ve por su calidad
de producción y de dirección
espectacular es una temporada más oscura
con personajes más desarrollados y con
temas musicales icónicos los dos últimos
capítulos que son largos como películas
se estrenarán el primero de julio sos
esto sea
nos quedamos con el arte audiovisual
para hablar ahora de la censura que
sufre la nueva película animada de
disney y pixar light ser la obra
centrada en naves light que era el
famoso guardián espacial de la saga toy
story no se estrenará en 14 países por
urgir un beso entre dos personajes
femeninos en un comunicado la oficina
reguladora de medios de emiratos árabes
unidos indicó por ejemplo que la
izquierda viola los estándares de
contenido en medios a esta provisión se
sumaron entre otros países indonesia a
egipto el urbano una gracia donde la
homosexualidad es considerada un delito
una isla de pocos segundos que los
estudios pixar habían cortado
inicialmente pero que tras la presión de
varios empleados de pixar y disney había
sido reincorporada
mientras que en francia se celebra la
gran fiesta internacional del cine
animado hasta el 18 de junio el festival
de ansys en esta edición número 46 las
obras que compiten son muy diversas con
películas de japón bélgica portugal
países bajos eeuu letonia y fueron las
famosas pequeñas criaturas amarillas de
los minions 2 quienes lanzaron el
festival el lunes 13 de junio
y del lado de méxico los descendientes
del fallecido escritor colombiano
gabriel garcía márquez encontraron en su
casa del sur de la capital una caja con
multitud de cartas escritas por pablo
neruda bill clinton robert redford o
fidel castro- entre muchos nombres
famosos el público podrá descubrir estas
correspondencias dentro de la exposición
gabo cuarenta años después del premio
nobel
ellos no escriben cartas pero escribir
en letras de canciones son los artistas
que estrenaron nuevos temas esta semana
empezando por el australiano venció a
quien declara su amor a cataluña en la
canción cataluña con un videoclip que
huele a verano y que muestra bien el
tono de wall street- time el tercer
álbum indie pop folk del cantautor
[Música]
y con legolas
el nigeriano y estrella de la música
from history se hace una declaración de
amor a su futura esposa la actriz demi o
ted ahora la pareja se comprometió en
abril cuando éste le propuso matrimonio
durante el rodaje de este vídeo en la
romántica ciudad de venecia en italia
nos despedimos con la voz cautivadora de
camelia jordana y el videoclip de su
tema muy guay y rey que ella misma
dirige en el sur de francia gracias por
su confianza y cuídense
[Música]